hello everybody and welcome to episode
five of buying and selling in freeto
play RuneScape uh last episode we ended
the episode at about 2 mil so we're
getting really close to a bond uh
however we're going to probably go to at
least three or four mil as um once we
buy the bond we want to have a little
bit of money left over to flip with um
yeah so we're just going to jump right
into this episode here so we're going to
start off by selling the myal plate legs
I'll be honest I cannot remember what I
bought these for we're just dumping them
I'm sure we broke even the least
and um for the second item we're going
to do the iron PL legs again uh last
time we only managed to buy one but
hopefully it's time we can get a couple
more because we did make about 30k on
each one so that's that's pretty good
and yeah so we're going to try to buy
them for 85k a piece and we're going to
try 10 I don't think I'll buy them all
but hopefully we'll get a couple more
than just
one okay and for the last item we are
going to do pure Essence we've done a
lot but I mean it works really well I'm
just checking here I think it just has a
one GP margin
uh but still as I get more money it's
definitely more effective to buy items
like this so we're going to try I think
80,000 um so if we buy them all we
should make an easy well 80k and yeah so
we'll check back when uh some stuff has
happened all right so we locked out
quite a lot uh and what I mean by that
is yeah we sold the mythal play legs
whatever um but the pure Essence we got
a 3gp margin on it cuz it Rose by 3gp
which is insane lucky so I made three
times amount of money I wanted on that
and um yeah so we'll just check my
history here I believe let's start with
P Ence yeah so we bought them for 720k
and sold them for 960 so that's 250k
almost right there super easy only took
like a day of waiting and the iron plate
legs made 40K so that's that's really
good too I wish I'd bought a couple more
of those but yeah know that was really
successful I was like 300K and yeah
let's try to repeat that okay so we're
going to start with the pure Essence
again uh just worked so well last time
there's no reason not to try again um we
just check it quickly it does look like
it has a 1 GP margin again which is good
uh fell back down to 9gp I can buy it
for um and again I check Rus buddy for
just the historic value of the the item
um so you can see here it's been around
the 9gp mark for quite a while um so
it's really safe to buy it I mean if you
look back far enough it was down to
eight but I'm fairly safe buying this
item
um so what we're going to do is just
plop it in for nine we're safe by I
think we're going to get 100K of them uh
whereas say I looked it up there was a
2gp margin but between 13 GP and 15 GP
if I look at that graph I probably
wouldn't buy it uh because there's quite
High likelihood of it crashing back
down uh and yeah continuing on we're
going to go with the iron plate legs
again uh we're going to try to buy a
couple more they work pretty well but
they are slow to buy I kind of realized
after the fact that the price I put in
here is probably way too low um but
we'll see maybe we'll get a couple who
knows and um yeah so for the last item
we are going to do the trusty admin
plate legs again um so we're going to
check the margin here I think I think it
was five or 6K uh which isn't the best
it's been but it's still quite a bit
better than a lot of other items um so
we tried 10K to buy it for didn't work
so we're going to plop in 25K and I
think we buy it for around the 14 k Mark
I guess yeah and sell it for eight
approximately so that's a 6K margin
still pretty good and uh we'll buy a
couple of these and we'll check back
probably not for a while because we're
buying 100K pure Ence so that'll take at
least eight hours if we're lucky all
right that's it we're not waiting any
longer these pesant are taking forever
to buy so we're going to cut in here um
so we bought and sold the plate legs
pretty nice profit I mean definitely
dropped a bit um but whatever
and uh we did abandon the iron plate
legs as they were not going anywhere so
that too bad but we'll just find a
better item um so we'll check the
history here I mean the margin did drop
but we still made about 60k on the admin
plate
legs and um another good piece of good
news is the pure Essence actually rose
up to 11 so we should get a two GP
margin on that as well uh so we should
be looking to make about 150k on that
okay we finally found a second item here
um so we're going to go with the mythal
play legs G had about a 3K margin on it
and uh we'll try buying 50 but you know
probably won't get them all and for the
last item here we are going to try
actually the party hat Set uh first time
we're trying this uh we check it it
actually has a pretty decent margin of
about 8 or 9k um while it's not as good
as the plate legs and stuff like that
sometimes these are traded a lot more
frequently um see I see there's about an
8K margin and um if you look at the
graph here fairly low and you see
there's five 600 traded every day
whereas the random armor we've been
buying has like a tenth of that usually
like 50 or 60 um so this should go
quickly and make an 8 ke 8K on each one
is I think it's pretty good still um so
we're going to try to put in some around
15 and uh yeah we'll see how these
work okay so we've sold a couple things
and we've switched one item around start
with P Ence thatat was the same we sold
them for 11 uh that great the the other
thing was not working so we said [__] it
we'll just go with the um the bucket and
um the bucket Helm sorry and uh the
party hat sets we got five of them so
we'll just check our history here um the
pure Essence like I was saying we made
about 150k on you can't see it here uh
the party hat sets went pretty well
while it was a little split up there you
can see we made see that's about 250k
and what so we made about 40K on the
um the Hat sets and the bucket Helm we
made
about 60k actually on so yeah it's
pretty good I was pretty happy with all
that and we're ending the episode at
about 2500 so we made 500k really easy
really quickly and if you notice we
actually have enough for a bond right
now so on paper we actually did it in
about five episodes uh so really didn't
take too long I think anyone could
really do it uh it's not hard flipping
it's actually quite easy really and
probably the fastest way to get money
and free to play um so yeah thanks for
watching the the series series we're
going to do a couple more episodes like
I said to get up to the four or five mil
Mark um to buy the bond so we'll have
some money left over uh and yeah thanks
for checking it out uh if you enjoyed
the video please hit that subscribe
button or just leave a comment and yeah
I'll see you guys in the next episode
[Music]